[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à tunis mohamed yazid ministre de
l'information du fln a lu aux
journalistes communiqué de tripoli n'en
attend c'est le terme des communiqués le
gpr à pour poursuivre les négociations
en cours
[Musique]
alger cependant de nouveaux attentats
d'importantes mesures d'ordre était
prise la ville était totalement
quadrillé par la troupe la surveillance
quotidienne été renforcée
[Musique]
et alger connaissait la grève des
postiers il fallait après s'être soumis
à la fouille venir retirer son courrier
dans les centres de distribution
installée dans les cinémas
[Musique]
l'armée poursuit sa mission et ses
forces en multipliant les contrôles de
prévenir ou de limiter les actes de
terrorisme
et ce matin là alger a été brusquement
arrachés au sommeil par une série de
violentes déflagrations
plus de 120 explosions se sont succédé
aux quatre coins de la ville et les
dégâts matériels ont été considérables
une forte charge de plastique a détruit
le câble de retenue du téléphérique dont
la cabine a fait une chute vertigineuse
de 400 m
[Musique]
en déclenchant ce feu roulant de
plasticages le wes at elle voulu
entreprendre une nouvelle et
spectaculaire action d'intimidation
auprès de la population algéroise
[Musique]
pas de vrai triomphe aux états unis sans
la consécration de new york john glenn à
la tête des six cosmonautes du projet
mercury a donc connu l'hommage de
broadway baptisée pour l'occasion le
chemin des astronomes
[Musique]
dans ce pays le degré de la gloire se
mesure au nombre de tonnes de papier
répandus et john glenn a tout lieu
d'être satisfait ça douar à ferrals et
autant de tonnes de serpentins et de
vote à déchiqueter que celle de l'hymne
verdun avait obtenu 35 ans plus tôt
1750 tonnes
1927 lindbergh avait réussi le premier
vol sans escale new york paris 1962
glenn a réussi un périple de trois tours
de terre il n'est sans doute pas
indifférent que les deux hommes est
déchaîné un égal enthousiasme à précieux
de gagarine et de titeuf en tout cas les
lauriers de glenn qui a ajouté à sa
panoplie de médailles celle de la ville
de new york n'ont pas fini d'en pêcher
les jeunes de dorny
[Musique]
l'un de ces jeunes justement jean louis
sartoux vient de se signaler tout
spécialement à l'attention des foules à
la suite d'expériences balistique mener
secrètement dans un pavillon de la
région parisienne mauvaise mise au point
toujours est il que sa dernière
expérience peut se résumer ainsi ils
voulaient expédié sa fusée dans la lune
il n'a réussi qu'à envoyer son père à
l'hôpital
monsieur sartoux père metteur en scène
de théâtre de semble cependant avoir
gardé aucune amertume de sa
collaboration malheur on
est un peu plus prudent
je ferai attention double non en tant
que père est également propriétaire je
retourne pas qu'ils fassent sauter la
maison mais
recommencera
un certain moment de l'année tous les
astrologues vous le diront le soleil
quitte le signe des poissons pour celui
du bélier le calendrier les approuvent
c'est ce qu'on appelle le printemps on
le reconnaît du reste à certains signes
le jardinier se plante soudain immobile
devant le premier bourgeon l'homme des
villes s'arrête lui devant les vitrines
de graines et d'outils de jardinage
cherchant le râteau labège de ses rêves
enfantins
est ce la proche du terme mais la
concierge arbore un nouveau sourire et
les chaises des parcs publics se
retrouvent tomates à 2 à 2
[Applaudissements]
l'homme pour qui les jo sont atroces
maux quotidiens se sentent une âme
meneur et s'aperçoit soudain qu'il a
absolument besoin de rectifier son noeud
papillon il saute avec une parfaite
netteté que la chance l'accompagnent
et que rien désormais ne peut l'empêcher
de gagner le gros lot d'un million et
demi de nouveaux francs de la tranche de
printemps justement
labertit l'au-delà grosses sociétés
pétrolières votée par dix ans de
soumission inconditionnelle services
qu'elle ne peut plus attendre un jour de
plus pour mettre une robe légère
[Musique]
mais les robes légères attire le regard
et desquels apparaissent au dehors gare
aux conséquences que cela comporte pour
les automobilistes
le printemps on vous dit
[Musique]
la récente affaire engelvin et ses
rebondissements successifs ont ramené la
tension sur le trafic de la drogue
chacun sait quelque chose de profits
réside dans ces petits paquets de poudre
blanche qui s'échange sous le manteau
contre de gros billets à 20 milles et
même à 50 mille anciens francs le gramme
le bénéfice est énorme
l'héroïne est donc une gigantesque
affaire pour les gangs qui la
commercialise
c'est pourquoi lé interpol l'organisme
international qui regroupe toutes les
polices du monde réserve dans son
répertoire du crime une place de choix à
ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler les
trafiquants de neige combien dans cet
énorme fichier qui comporte quelque cent
cinquante mille noms et marjo
fantastique bénéfices que rapporte ce
vice dont l'exploitation a suscité la
croissance d'une industrie à l'échelle
du monde
[Musique]
la carte de l'interpol invite que le
centre de la chine demeure semble-t-il
avec ses dix-sept mille hectares de
tavaux le grain producteur d'opium cette
pierre mais dirigée sur hong kong plaque
tournante du trafic qui chaque année on
voit passer entre ces bicoques
surpeuplées et cessant pas pourri 300
tonnes de quoi fabriquer 20 tonnes
d'héroïne
dont hong kong au moyen-orient la route
de l'opium est relativement ouverte
c'est à partir de cet endroit qu'elle
devient plus surveillé est moins sûr
pour le trafiquant car c'est point
d'aboutissement se trouvent surtout en
espagne et en france que l'interpol
définit comme le centre des officines de
transformation de l'opium en héroïne
dans les banlieues des grandes villes
sous des apparences banale se dessine
elle de petits laboratoires clandestins
qui traite la drogue de façon certes
artisanale mais à tout prendre efficace
et qui tire de 15 kilos d'opium un kilo
d'héroïne
récemment la brigade des stupéfiants
n'at-elle pas pensé trouver dans les
communs du château d'augerville la
rivière l'un de ses laboratoires secrets
consacré au culte de la drogue et voir
dans son propriétaire le docteur coop
ici entre deux policiers au lieu d'un
paisible chercheur scientifique qu'il
prétend être l'un de ces fabricants du
terrible poison ce poisson ne reste en
france que pour une quantité infime
c'est l'amérique qui en fait la plus
grosse consommation c'est donc la route
des états unis que surveille plus
spécialement la police paquebot luxueux
ou cargo vulgaire peuvent recéler temps
de recoins discret tant de possibles
cachette malgré tout la drogue arrive
encore trop souvent et la chaîne du
trafic s'étire en toile d'araignée sur
le pays entier il n'est pas rare de voir
la brigade des stupéfiants saisir ici et
là un stock d'héroïne coffret un
trafiquant mais le gang de la drogue est
hélas pas encore décapité
[Musique]
et
championnats du monde de ski au tremplin
de 90 m à zakopane en pologne ce
concurrent nous invite à faire le saut
avec lui
[Musique]
mais
et donne l'impression d'un oiseau il ne
semble pas qu'il est à faire des efforts
pour conserver son équilibre un sauteur
c'est aussi presque une fusée une fusée
qui éclatent parfois avant d'atteindre
ressemble
[Musique]
les uns après les autres tous ses
concurrents s'offrent des vols planés de
près de 100 m
c'est également vrai que nagl qui va le
plus loin il atteint 103 m
[Musique]
et par la même occasion il obtient le
titre de champion du monde
[Musique]
voix
entre la colline de bougies que 2000
l'hôtel suisse d horizon bleu et evian
le ballet des hélicoptères a repris
chaque jour les journalistes en ont vu
descendre trois par trois les délégués
du gpr une conviction leur du cessez le
feu approchait mais une conviction
seulement autour de l'hôtel du parc le
secret reste est en effet bien gardés
au casino où les négociateurs français
messieurs louis joxe robert buron et
jean de braye était venu se mêler aux
journalistes aucun renseignement n'a
percé la négociation simplement avancé
et sans doute était ce là l'essentiel
[Musique]
issy les moulineaux cependant était le
théâtre du plus odieux des attentats que
l'ol c'est comme il jusqu'ici en france
l'explosion d'une voiture piégée
faisaient trois morts deux gardiens de
la paix le vaguemestre d'une institution
religieuse et 47 blessées dont cinq
écoliers
[Musique]
la sauvagerie aveugle de ce crime devait
provoquer dès l'après-midi le
rassemblement de milliers de personnes
autour du maire d'issy les moulineaux la
foule devait flétrir les auteurs d'un
attentat qui a été perpétré dans un lieu
passant près d'un établissement public
face à un édifice public dont les locaux
abritent des cours d'enseignement
on ne valait rien le ministre des
anciens combattants monsieur raymond
triboulet a inauguré le parcours du
souvenir ce chemin que parcourt est une
dernière fois les patriotes pour aller
se recueillir à la chapelle avant de
tomber sur la butte des fusillés
[Musique]
le ministre s'est longuement recueilli
devant le mémorial de la france
combattante dédié à tous ceux qui avec
ou sans uniformes sont morts au combat
durant la guerre 39 45
[Musique]
c'est villefranche sur saône que la
fortune a choisi pour faire un homme
heureux monsieur qu'est peintre en
lettres s'est en effet trouvé du jour au
lendemain la tête de 40 millions
d'anciens francs grâce à la loterie
nationale nous lui avons demandé de nous
raconter son histoire
à l'autre je passais rue nationale puis
d'habitude je prenais un billet un
visuel puis tout d'un coup ça met plus
de rentrer dans le bus au tabac et j'ai
pris un entier le premier venu qui fait
devant moi que le lob mais j'ai j'ai
regardé sur le veulent ce journal
régional et j'ai constaté que j'avais eu
le tir est
numéro 1 85 mille six cent cinquante
groupes de je ne promets pas et puis
alors à ce moment là les amis m'ont dit
de verica a gagné le gros lot de gros
lot de la loterie qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé ce jour là à prendre a dit y est
entier j'avais l'intuition de gagner
d'ordinaire mans je prenais un dixième
et ce jour là comme j'avais cette
intuition qui étrenne entier pour
l'instant je continue mon travail a par
la suite je sais pas ce que je ferai
mais de toute façon j'achèterai encore
un billet de la loterie nationale
la vie moderne encombré de technico
précision de plus en plus poussée exige
des hommes qui la vivent mais attention
toujours en éveil un sang-froid parfait
une résistance nerveuse à toute épreuve
[Musique]
lorsque l'on considère les pilotes des
avions militaires ou civils en présence
des responsabilités qui sont les leurs
et dont dépend d'abord leur vie ensuite
celles qui leur sont confiées on imagine
sans peine quelle précision et l
exactitude doivent avoir leurs réflexes
surtout aux vitesses que peuvent
atteindre les appareils à réaction pour
le mirage s'est plusieurs fois la
vitesse du son
si cette technique impeccable peut être
atteinte par un entraînement intensif il
va de soi que rien ne doit pouvoir l'a
troublé et l'alcool est sévèrement exclu
mais ces conditions dont le caractère
impératif apparaît à l'évidence devant
le spectacle de dizaines de cadres ans
ne sont pas moins essentiel au reste du
monde
l'ouvrier devant son tour le chauffeur
devant son volant sont tributaires de la
même précision des réflexes de la même
résistance nerveuse au milieu des
conditions de la vie moderne
il reste que la précision des évolutions
des avions les plus rapides traduite
avec éloquence le merveilleux équilibre
physique nerveux et cérébral de ce hack
in son bon pied et que ceci ne saurait
conserver sens là ça brille été
entre du style à l'objet appelé
l'inspiration sur les créateurs d'objets
voilà le but de cette exposition dont le
besoin se faisait sentir le coffret à
bijoux ya gagné des biceps sans doute
pour mieux défendre son trésor la
commode s'est mué en arbre à tiroirs si
depuis longtemps l'objet usuel
manifestait une médiocrité de forme et
d'invention lamentable voici qui va
changer tout cela
finie la psyché simplette d'autrefois ce
miroir aux alouettes c'est son nom
permet à la beauté de bien plus étrange
fantasmagorie
mais il ya d'autres découvertes à faire
dans cette exposition pour l'amateur qui
veut meubler sa maison selon les
concepts du nouveautés à la pointe même
de l'art message poétique
quelle étrange signe de connivence ne
laisserait pas la main rêver sur la
tablette de ce secrétaire fantastique et
cette baignoire arraché à une atlantide
disparu à quel sirène captive à quel
lorelei et elle par avance destinée même
le lit le lit banal d'hier est devenu à
la fois triomphal et parsifal hien le
meuble clé des anciens vaudeville à
recouvrer la grandeur des fables
classique et s'il affecte la forme d'un
demi cercle on peut tout de même
supposer qu'il se trouvera à 1 100
[Musique]
150 artistes ont donc réalisé sans
préjuger de techniciens ces formes
nouvelles rassemblement disparates
inattendu peut être scandaleux ou
dérisoire mais il n'empêche qu'il posera
des problèmes
troublera l'attention et c'est peut-être
à ce prix que des gens de métier
retrouverons une inspiration égarés et
que se dégagera un style original
puis de notre temps
quarts de finale de la coupe de france
ou par les passes opposant nancy maillot
blanc au stade de france
[Applaudissements]
les rémois que pas en tête numéro 9
n'ont décidément pas de chance cette
année chaque fois qu'il domine pas
l'adversaire il leur manque toujours le
petit coup de pouce du destin et quand
le destin serait de la partie c'est pour
précipiter les événements avant le début
de la partie a été marqué par la gente
amoureux pour nancy qui n'en espéraient
pas tant
et
à evian sous les fenêtres de l'hôtel du
parc la tempête du lac s'est apaisée
symbole peut-être est tour à tour
belkacem krim et la délégation fln louis
joxe et la délégation française se sont
encore une fois retrouvée mais cette
fois pour conclure
dr qui passe trop lentement au gré des
journalistes qui assiège la porte et
soudain après douze jours de discussions
serrées la salle des délibérations se
retrouvent silencieuse et vite pendant
que les hélicoptères remporte au dessus
du lac la délégation algérienne les
ministres français quittent l'hôtel les
sourires annonce qu'une grandeur attendu
depuis plus de sept ans va sonner
et le soir même à les viser le général
de gaulle pouvait annoncer aux foules
française la conclusion du cessez le feu
en algérie
les dispositions adoptées
pour que les populations
il dispose de vesta
la perspective qui s'ouvre sur
l'avènement d'une algérie indépendante
coopérant étroitement avec nous
satisfont la raison de la forme ce qui
va être
entreprise pour tirer d'une lutte
déplorable les chances d'un avenir fico
est dû au peuple français
car c'est lui qui
par son beau sens
sa solidité
sac confiance
constamment témoigner à qu'il porte la
charge de conduire l'état et la nation a
permis que mûrissent puis aboutisse la
solution
le général de gaulle annonce est ainsi
de cessez-le-feu le président du gpk
monsieur ben raide à qui en avait fait
l'annoncé du côté fln était porté en
triomphe à l'air de tunis où il
s'embarquait pour gagner à bâle où il
accueillerait benbella libéré
dans alger à demi paralysé par des
grèves une sorte de grand silence s'est
appesanti ces derniers jours les six
victimes de ben aknoun six dirigeants
des centres sociaux parmi lesquels
l'écrivain mouloud feraoun ont été
inhumés devant leurs cercueils 2
ministre monsieur guillaume à hebei ont
rappelé leur action et apporté l'hommage
du gouvernement
[Musique]
dans le centre de la ville où
l'abattement semble avoir succédé à
l'anxiété des derniers jours les
consignes de grève générale donnée aux
européens ont vidé les rues seul sur les
places et dans les rues semé de chicanes
et des barrages les éléments de l'armée
contrôle d'une circulation réduite à
zéro
les autobus sont restés au garage les
magasins sont fermés les ateliers
gardent leur portes closes un silence
pesant règne
réprobation inquiétudes réflexion il y a
de tout dans ce silence et même
peut-être de l'espérance
c'est un ami que la france a reçu en la
personne de monsieur françois tombalbaye
président de la république et chef du
gouvernement du tchad au cours d'une
visite de trois jours commencé à les
viser par un entretien avec le général
de gaulle
[Musique]
paris a salué sur les champs elysées ce
jeune chef d'état de 43 ans au moment où
il allait se recueillir sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu
monsieur françois tombalbaye et le 9e
des chefs d'état de l'afrique
d'expression française que la france ait
reçu depuis l'accession de leur pays à
l'indépendance en 1960 il est aussi
celui qui a pu dire mon pays a été le
premier a rallié la france libre 1940
je vient confirmer cette amitié
auj
à genève la conférence ou plutôt le
comité du désarmement s'est ouvert avec
seulement 17 de ses participants sur 18
une place en effet resté vide celle de
la france dont le scepticisme est du
reste connu quant aux chances possibles
d'une telle conférence
dès les premières réunions il semble
bien du reste que les points de vue
américain et russe se soient confirmés
fondamentalement inconciliables il reste
comme voici quinze ans séparés par la
question capitale du contrôle
[Musique]
spectacle insolite sur la plage de
cannes que n'aurait pas imaginé les
familiers de la croisette l'ancien
paquebot français de grass devenu
italien sous le nom de venezuela s'est
échoué à 200 mètres du rivage les 190
passagers sont sains et saufs mais les
opérations de renflouement se révèle
délicate et le sort du navire de 18
mille tonnes restent des plus incertains
[Musique]
voici exactement 30 ans le monde entier
suivait avec une attention horrifié les
développements d'un drame affreux
l'enfant de charles lindbergh qui était
l'idole des foules depuis sa traversée
de l'atlantique
un bébé de 20 mois avait été enlevé dans
son berceau au premier étage de la villa
que ses parents habitaient à la campagne
le kidnappeur avait en descendant cassé
l'échelle dont il s'était servi lundi ce
devait servir plus tard la demande d'une
rançon de 50 mille dollars appuyé sur
l'envoi de pièces d'habillement du bébé
fut discutée par un étrange personnage
le docteur condom qui devait plus tard
assuré reconnaître la voix de son
correspondant anonyme puis on retrouva
le bébé est mort il avait dû tomber
quand l'échelle c'est theron
plus tard un billet de la rançon remis à
un poste d'essence mis la police sur la
trace d'un certain richard hoffman
charpentier en perpétuelle chômage qu'on
arrête à la maison qu'ils habitaient fut
soumise à une perquisition minutieuse et
le garage qui lui servait d'atelier
complètement disséqués
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on y retrouva dans un bidon une partie
de la rançon les numéros des billets
correspondait à la liste établie par la
banque au moment de leur remise aux
kidnappeurs hoffman allaient-ils avoué
nom
et au palais de justice de flemington
s'ouvrit deux ans et demi après
l'enlèvement ce qu'on appela alors le
procès du siècle 300 journalistes et
radio reporters étaient venus du monde
entier
le procès devait durer trente deux jours
pendant lesquels hawkman tint tête aux
attaques du procureur
[Musique]
mais les indices semblaient convaincant
hoffmann fut condamné à main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en voyant patiner le jeune canadien
donald klaxons tous les concurrents des
championnats du monde à prague on tue
des complexes dans ces conditions
jackson était certain de remporter le
titre
ce qu'il a réussi avec beaucoup de brio
bien que les juges n'aient pas eu pour
lui des regards très tendre
ce n'est pas là le seul titre de
champion du monde décerné au canada en
couple léger inec qui sont canadiens eux
aussi bien que leurs noms l'indiquent
pas ont effectué la meilleure exhibition
et pourtant leurs numéros ne s'est pas
passé sans accroc
le public qui connaît les difficultés du
patinage ne leur en tient pas rigueur
et la fin de leur exhibition méritait
bien qu'on leur attribue le titre de
champion du monde
[Musique]
0 0 c'était le score à la mi temps du
match monaco nîmes les nîmois en maillot
légèrement plus foncé que les
monégasques ont bien du mal à prouver
qu'ils sont les candidat numéro un au
titre de champion de france de football
de fait monaco comme en ce moment même
le plus souvent l'offensive mais et tout
cela est mièvre étriqué bref sans grande
est un sel comme ce tir de l'ailier
gauche qu'aux
monaco finit cependant par marquer un
but à un quart d'heure de la fin du
match j'ai dû changer la face des choses
le match soit tout à coup de la
grisaille et on assiste à un véritable
spectacle sportif qui ne fait cependant
pas tremblé deux passions les
spectateurs dans les tribunes
les nîmois attaque avec beaucoup de
réalisme un certain brio et aussi un peu
de réussite
résultat il marque un but eux aussi
juste à temps pour obtenir un match nul
somme toute assez équipés
si vous aimez la neige si vous ne savez
pas vous tenir sur des skis et si vous
appréciez la vitesse alors fait du spic
les scouts qui utilisent désormais les
canadiens ce cas la fois un traîneau
maïak est un acte
ce nouveau vaisseau des neiges
l'avantagé déplacer à la vitesse d'une
voiture de course plus de 160 à l'heure
avec le bruit évidemment ça manque
peut-être un peu de poésie
oui
[Musique]
pour entendre le message par lequel le
chef de l'état lui annoncer les accords
d'evian l'assemblée s'est réunie ainsi
début de cette semaine ce film de la
sphère d'algérie qui devait se tâcher de
sang et que nous allons dérouler devant
dans la capitale marocaine arabe a
déclaré rld enthousiasme avait salué
l'arrivée de benbella solennellement
accueillis par le roi hassan 2 venus de
tunis ou de genève le gpr à au complet
se pressaient autour de l'ex prisonnier
quelques jours plus tard monsieur
christian fouchet n'a mené au
commissaire en algérie arrivé au rocher
noir ou monsieur jean morin lui
présenter ses services dès son arrivée
monsieur christian fouchet adressait à
la population algérienne des paroles
émouvantes vous êtes en ce moment ceux
qui souffraient le plus je viens ici
pour vous aider c'est que le drame déjà
avait éclaté déjà à oran attaqué par des
commandos as les troupes ripostait dans
les rues étroites ont tiré des terrasses
sur les crs établissez le quadrillage ou
dénombré trois morts on comptait 66
blessés bilan tragique qui devait les
jours suivants s'accentuer lourdement
[Musique]
dans cette ville dont les murs
montraient des traces du combat les
fouilles opérées dans un immeuble avait
cependant permis une prise importante
l'ex-général jour le second de salins
disparu depuis le putsch du 22 avril
dont il avait été l'un des quatre chefs
on l'avait aussitôt transféré à la santé
mais alger couvrait sous ses murs blancs
un drame plus tragique encore bab
el-oued le vieil alger européens aux
lisières de la casbah livrer bataille
des forces régulières
folie criminelle que de peut expliquer
le ferment du désespoir drame des noms
ciel dans lequel le sang a coulé
à
dans cette ville meurtrie par des
combats qui n'aurait pas dû naître en
compta des deux côtés les morts et les
blessés par dizaines et bab el-oued
réduit meurtrier fut bouclée d'un
bouclage sans fissure pendant que les
responsables aient fait laine maintenait
l'ordre chez les musulmans voisin
ravitailler bab el-oued bouclé
bab-el-oued fouillé des caves ou
greniers bab el-oued peut être affamés
devint le souci des algérois des
collectes des quêtes s'opérait en pleine
rue avant que puisse intervenir la
possibilité d'un ravitaillement plus
normal
mais le drame de bab el-oued va-t-il
continuer ou plutôt pour rire l'écho des
rafales de mitraillettes ne s'est ainsi
que pour se réveiller plus loin dans ce
réduit cerner sous la menace des cas
nous verrons nous inscrire encore
d'autres drames verrons-nous tomber
d'autres meurent seront ils c'est mort
de bab el oued les derniers d'une guerre
finie qui ouvre comme le dit le général
de gaulle un nouvel avenir et pour nous
mêmes
notre référendum revêt une importance
exprès
faire et justement au sujet de la grave
à terre algérienne
la preuve éclatante de notre unité et de
notre volonté
c'est marqué que nous sommes capables de
résoudre
délibérément un grand problème de notre
temps
la france va reprendre le chemin des
urnes à ce propos une constatation lors
du dernier référendum la france a battu
un record celui de l'abstention quelques
six millions d'électeurs plus de 26 % du
corps électoral se sont abstenus c'est à
dire un français sur quatre
26% c'est à dire le quart de la
population appelée à voter
26% qui n'ont pas dit mot soit parce que
ce jour-là la campagne semblait plus
attrayante que le bureau de vote
soit parce que c'est dans tauzin vide
près semble des évents terre il a voulu
donner raison à une image d'épinal
depuis longtemps traditionnelle
soit qu'un incident imprévisible un
accident de la rue pourrait-on dire les
détourner du droit chemin
le français au peuple politique n'est
pas particulièrement tarder à remplir
son devoir de citoyen ferry on va
arrêter
le sport ni ça les intéresse peu que les
conflits naissent ou s'éteignent que les
menaces mon tout s'apaise avec tout ce
que ces bouleversements leurs réserves à
eux mêmes car ils ont eu hier ils ont
aujourd'hui en votant la possibilité de
faire valoir leur point de vue leur wii
ou leur nom à une valeur et qu'on ne
vienne pas dire qu'est ce qu'une voix
sur 25 millions c'est oublier que ces 25
millions de voix ne sont faites que de
l'addition des voix de chacun au lieu
que l'abstention ce refus du oui ou du
non c'est la signature en blanc le
pouvoir en blanc le chèque en blanc la
liberté donnée d'agir en votre nom sans
votre contrôle et peut-être contre vous
et vous vous êtes du même coup refusé le
droit de critiquer de juger de discuter
le monde ne s'arrêtera pas pour vous
proposerez vous opposition de kennedy ou
de coacher cas l'inflexion si minime que
vous la pensiez aurez vous donner à ces
problèmes qui agitent la nation le monde
et même la vie de tous les jours tout se
fera comme si vous n'existiez pas et
avec votre approbation puisque c'est
avec votre silence
mais dans les feuilles du jour n'y at il
que les bandes dessinées
et
[Musique]
auvergnat écrivain pamphlétaire
philosophe à cet homme de science que ne
fut pas blaise pascal
mathématicien il est un as par sa
précocité à 19 ans il inventait la
première machine à calculer
physicien ses expériences au puy de dôme
puis à la tour saint jacques sur la
pression atmosphérique sont restés
célèbres d'aucuns affirment qu on lui
doit aussi la brouette
mais sait-on qu'il fut en 1662 voici
exactement 300 ans le promoteur des
transports en commun parisiens avec la
création des 45 salle
il fallut pourtant atteindra décret de
napoléon iii pour voir s'organiser
véritablement ses transports à paris
onze compagnies faisaient alors circuler
dans la capitale quelques trois cent
cinquante huit voitures à chevaux de
toutes catégories
certains projets du reste confiante à 4
malheureux chevaux à un train entier de
voitures à six roues était restée sans
lendemain la compagnie générale des
omnibus uniformiser les systèmes et le
progrès suivi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit au chara dans succédé le tramway
tracté sur rails mais on reprocher à ce
chemin de fer à l'américaine de nuire à
l'esthétique on lui préféra l'homme des
bus à impériale vint enfin les voitures
à traction automobile
nés entre temps il y avait une urgence
bienvenue le père du métro dès 1900 le
chemin de fer souterrain transformer le
sous-sol de paris en une gigantesque
taupinière le métro entre et
délibérément dans les moeurs l'idée de
pascal havet en somme fait son chemin
nous connaissons la suite familier du
métro et des autobus
nous regretterons pourtant que pascal
n'est pas sa station ce serait une
justice à l'iran
[Musique]
disparu depuis un siècle une toile de
léonard de vinci le seul ni les pins se
trouve-t-elle aujourd'hui chez un
marchand de tableaux lyonnais entre une
oeuvre d'ingres et intérêts
[Musique]
le sonic youth en effet ne doute pas
qu'ils possèdent là les dao signe
autrement dit une fortune à l'appui de
sa conviction il souligne la parenté de
l'oeuvre qu'il possède avec la toile de
léonard de vinci dont le palais borghèse
à rome détient une copie
une étude du maître florentin se
superpose d'ailleurs étrangement à la
figure du tableau le voile enfin qui
couvre pudiquement la nudité n'est qu'un
repas ultérieure la led a perdu 9 ainsi
est-elle retrouver
[Musique]
l'équipe de france de rugby maillot
blanc culotte noire le match de cardiff
contre les gallois devait être selon les
spécialistes le match du triomphe de
fait dès les premières minutes de jeu on
y croit au triomphe des français ça
commence bien pour eux les attaques
comme celle ci fusent de toutes parts
seulement voilà les colosses gallois ne
se laisse pas du tout impressionné par
la réputation de leurs adversaires et la
chance aidant les gallois prennent
avantage sur coup franc 1 0 ce sera la
plus confiné
de temps à autres lorsqu'ils ont la
balle les trois quarts français font
illusion ici il attaque avec l'arrière
claude lacaze intercalé qui donne un
coup de pied de recentrage tout cela est
très joli mais inefficace inefficace
parce qu'il manque un tout petit quelque
chose à l'équipe de france et ce petit
quelque chose c'est la chance si l'on
ajoute à cela une certaine lenteur
d'exécution et beaucoup de maladresses
on se rend parfaitement compte que la
france ne peut pas gagner ce match et
puis décidément rien ne marche
les dernières minutes sont très pénibles
pour les français venus à cardiff pour
donner la leçon ils en sont réduits à se
défendre avant de perdre un match dont
il était pourtant archi favori
le palais des sports a offert au public
parisien un combat de poids plume qui
rappelait étrangement les grands combats
de la belle époque de la boxe en europe
pour un peu les vieux habitués des
salles parisiennes de combat se serait
cru revenu tu rentres en arrière et avec
un peu d'imagination
jean gabin n'aura pas eu de mal à se
persuader qu'il assistait à un véritable
championnat du monde de fait le cubain
sugar annonce culotte noire et de
nigériens rafiou kings sont deux
authentiques vedettes et les deux
boxeurs n'ont trompé personne ils se
sont livrées à fond du premier au
dernier rang chacun avec ses moyens
sugar amos tout en force et raf youqing
l'enfant chéri des parisiens tout en
souplesse et en décontraction le nigeria
un combat de boxe est une espèce de
petit balai un peu dilettante rafles ou
king a joué les lièvre de la fable il
s'est fait battre au sprint par amos
beaucoup plus lent que lui mais aussi
beaucoup plus régulier
il est
[Musique]